you need to live it how do you break
through by doing so much content for so
long that you start to get an
understanding of the thematics that work
if you think that I woke up one morning
and said you know what we're going to do
in [__] August 2023 on my Instagram
in this highly competitive environment
we're going to make a meme that captures
the essence of the video and we're going
to do a two poost Carousel cuz that's
going to get the most organic reach I
promise you I had no [__] idea if you
think I thought making photos that says
that has a picture of me in it that then
says the person that's sending you this
thinks and then whatever the [__] we've
written was going to be the consistent
million organic reach post I when I
first posted the first one I'm like this
has no
shot reps attention is the number one
asset all right awesome let's do it cool
um uh the only piece of advice I would
say here is like don't over think of
this as a one-on-one meeting don't try
to over think of like everybody else in
the room like everyone's individual
narrowness actually usually touches
everybody else in some way and then I'll
use that context as I go around the room
so let's lock in cool um so I've been
fortunate enough to um go viral
continually with the kaying business um
we have over like 400 million views yeah
the content is obviously so conducive
yeah if you were selling concrete it
wouldn't be as easy yeah yeah um part of
the the thought process um you know on
my daily work is like how do I convert
more of that to actual business by
taking the content that's gone viral and
slightly tweaking it and making it the
collateral that you advertise against
okay and let me say that one more time
for
everyone the greatest thing about
organic social right now is the
algorithms are not based anymore on what
they used to be which is like your
followers it's now based on the content
so social for the first 15 years was
more about like email marketing build
list Market to it get a percentage of
them to do stuff over the last two years
we've are fully in the process of the
Tik Tock ification of all social kind of
why I invested in Tumblr I invested in
Facebook and Twitter for the email thing
I invested in Tumblr for the content
thing meaning the social graph used to
be based on your social network now
social media could actually be called
interest media CU it's based on the
interest graph the shed could have 19
followers on LinkedIn tomorrow and
decide it wants to go and the first post
could get a million views if the post
itself was good so you have affirmation
from the world that they like this video
now two things come to mind one does
that equally mean that they want to buy
no and then two you've got to that part
you can't control the part you can
control is say okay this video got 4
million views organically on Instagram
Tik Tok YouTube shorts let me now retake
that video and make it much more
hard-hitting I'm going to put a banner
at the bottom that says order now
discount this let me change the copy so
taking the viral creative and turning it
into an ad the viral creative is
building brand the ad is building
performance we call this brand formance
right taking something that's gone well
organically and turning it into a
conversion a ticket selling app ad
excuse me yeah yeah that makes sense um
jumping over to like the franchise side
of it the franchise or side of it um how
would you go
about selling franchises by making
content on LinkedIn at scale okay you
should be putting out three posts a day
on
LinkedIn saying the same seven things
7,000 different ways of why they should
work with
you okay very know um yeah we put out a
bunch of content on on Instagram
Facebook T Instagram is impossible yeah
right like everything's about day
trading attention 2023 Instagram is not
Instagram right Instagram is impossible
meaning all that these social networks
are is supply and demand the reason I'm
always loud once every four years is
something is starting to have a lot of
demand that doesn't have enough Supply
yet enough of you have been in my
Circles of content consumption that all
of you can probably remember four years
ago I'm like Tik Tok TI Tik Tock and I
mean everyone across the board is sad
that they didn't listen to me as even if
they did it they didn't do it as I
didn't do it as hard as I thought I
wanted to like that as I wanted to it's
it's like this almost unachievable game
every time I remember promising myself
after Instagram that the next Instagram
that I was going to actually go 100% not
99 I was going to stop I was going to
let them all run the agency for a year I
am going to go 100% I literally see Tik
Tok when it's musically when we were
[__] in Park Avenue I'm like ear I
got it and I went like
49% so I know all of you went
12% so it's because it's supply and
demand I apologize it's like real estate
like when Tik Tok popped that was like
Malibu popping a 100 years ago and like
do you want to buy Beach fromont
property Because by the time you get to
Instagram today is like buying you're
not even in Malibu anymore that's how
far out it's so mature what happens is
more people today more content will be
produced for Instagram than any day in
the history of
Instagram however in the last four years
20 to 40% of that attention has gone to
in to gone to Tik Tock they've lost
attention today more ads will be spent
on Instagram than any day in the history
of
Instagram ads take up more attention
there's organic there's ads and there's
attention very simple framework so
Instagram to today is really hard the
only way you hack it is the stuff I talk
about best practices of the moment if
you watch my like look I'm going to
leave in an hour please promise me to
continue to watch what I'm doing even
harder than ever before why am I doing a
meme and then a video constantly over
the last 60 days on
Instagram and why am I doing a two poost
Carousel constantly where the first one
is a meme and the second one is the
video that was you were accustomed to
seeing me just post a video why am I
doing that I promise you it's not for
kicks and
Giggles it's what is now working of this
moment that can give you the most upside
when it's you know it's like if you're
the best player in your sixth grade
football team that's good but when you
get to high school it gets harder to be
the best player and then there's college
and then there's the pros Instagram now
is the pros if you're going to really go
crazy you got to be the best whereas
other platforms you could still be six
you know what I mean LinkedIn first of
all don't forget who's on LinkedIn if
they're why they're on LinkedIn and what
they're doing in there they're looking
for business opportunities so your
hard-hitting join my franchise is going
to hit harder in LinkedIn than it's
going to hit even to the same person if
Zach and Jack are just in their phone on
LinkedIn versus on Tik Tok in one place
they're looking to be entertained or
look at girls or I don't know what you
know the other place they're doing
business you're in you the same person
or a different person so you got to you
got to understand that okay and uh what
are your thoughts on Tik Tok ads versus
Facebook Instagram
ads for the so all the ad products are
evolving by the day there's a very good
CH so I'm writing a new book and it's
basically jab jab jab right hook again
but different but I've decided to change
it and I think I'm going to call it day
trading
attention because that's what that's
what sums up what I do for a living I'm
day trading
attention so like when you ask me that
question it was funny how my brain
paused because I have a hot take macro
answer but if I just double click a
little bit it becomes a very complicated
Nuance answer right Tik Tok because it's
a immature younger ad product it can be
highly
volatile it's like a four-year-old like
one day could be awesome and the next
day they could [__] their pants like Tik
tock can have bigger variables than
Instagram can but it could be [__]
crazy like one Tik Tok ad for you given
the visual of the kayaking thing could
lead to incredible amounts of
consumption on the consumer level on the
franchisee level I would run LinkedIn
ads you could literally run LinkedIn ads
against employees of other
franchisee and franchisor companies
these are highly likely to you know so I
think it's a mix and I think you got a
taste but you got to spend like $55 on
at the same ad on three different
platforms to see what's brewing it's the
the level of
like the thing that all of you need to
think about is like if you're going to
get into Peak Physical
shape like that's a lot of work that's a
level of like diet and exercise that is
like really [__] intense same in this
game if you're really going to go there
you have to like actually be great at it
like you know this the dream scenario is
like why people take apple vinegar like
[__] pills the dream scenario is I'm
going to tell you to post one video and
you're going to r one ad and you go to
sleep it's just not like that so that's
how I see that they all could work but I
do think if you're looking to get
franchises back to the joke of you're
going to run out of family members I
think LinkedIn needs to become a passion
okay yeah I do Post uh organic stuff on
there but I want to go harder on that
for sure yeah and is it hard-hitting
like is it deep like like yeah this is
why you should be a franchisee for my
[__] like that's a different you know
what I mean okay you know and then like
really give that thought like why should
they in a world of lots of options
what's the actual answer and then that
will force you to actually be
better yeah use testimonials from some
the other of course who's the most
successful franchisee that's is not
related to you in the system my brother
um not in the system uh in the system
not related yeah was a previous tour guy
that became a franchisee right I would
have that person I would do a podcast
that four people are going to watch
because that's where you're at just like
four people watch my early [__] but I
would do it to get
content for the
ads right I mean I would never like no
[__] like I love giving I I give
back all the time I do tons of stuff I
would never do what I'm doing right now
if we weren't filming this ever it's
just not I can't extract enough value
from the
time I enjoy it and like that's probably
a little bit [__] because I do
genuinely enjoy this and do tons of
things that are not Roi time positive
but what continues to drive me besides
wanting to support the Sasha group is
we're filming it and it's one sentence
to One answer that might be what I was
looking for right
now so like thinking in those ways
setting up certain things for the
content for the social not for the thing
I believe almost everyone should have a
podcast because having guests is a very
easy way to get content the shed should
absolutely have a daily to minimum
weekly podcast because it's an easy way
to create
creative I you like you have a guest
they're doing the work you ask them the
seven [__] cliche questions God
forbid the host has some improv
capabilities and can find the moment now
you're [__] I mean all of you live on
social the [__] do you think's in your
feet
half of it is [__] podcast clips and
the other half is like people on the
street asking you to like rate yourself
on how hot you are you know it's just
like you know what I mean like like it's
not complicated but it's very
complicated meaning it's a whole new
world create scenarios like kayaks can
have two people in it great I think you
should do a show where you're doing the
podcast while the kayaking is happening
can you have three people in a kayak uh
no but we could get multiple kayaks yeah
right but it's hard to stick like three
would have been a dream because then you
could have one the filmer and then you
could have the
interview I am already working on that
um I'm doing an adventurous clear series
because we have the all clear kayaks and
um I go and interview the franchisee of
every location or the lead can I ask you
something I'm sorry I'm I'm stuck right
now I think you need to build some sort
of thing okay and you should literally
do a podcast that is happening while the
Kay like I think one of the biggest
genres of content creation is podcast
while other action is happening yeah
like I've been dying for somebody to do
a brushing your teeth podcast like I
want a double
sync I want the host brushing their
teeth the guest brushing their teeth
that's the show like brushing Through
The Years or I don't know fcking
cleaning up the day or like literally I
want a 24 Minute Podcast I'm
on I mean this we s i uh 137 my media
company I've been dying to do this we
have a show now called serial
entrepreneur
and in the episode both people are
eating cereal like hot ones did this
right with hot wings right like I was on
it like I think there's 3900 thank you
so much 3900 more hot wings seral
entrepreneurs to be made I'm telling you
right now I don't I didn't even know how
many people fit in a kayak if I saw in
my feed a podcast where the person cuz
it you're back to back right like this
right like the person's behind you right
I think I know enough about that like if
you're the lead if you're the
interviewer and you're like all right
but what why didn't you start oh [__]
why didn't you start the bit like that's
[__]
amazing fair enough I'll try it like
even your guys world you could literally
have a podcast where both people are are
Robo like controlling the Drone while
you're doing like I think people are
fascinated when people are doing two
things at
once I agree by the way was that Katie
that just handed you that that was I
went to high school
get out of here let's get her back
here I grew up with her brother that's
very far Ezra can you get me Katie from
My Team bring her back
here last quick question for you um how
do I overd deliver for my franchisees by
talking to them okay this is a really
interesting simple see how fast that
came super Insight by scheduling real
time to hear the truth okay the way you
can't the reason most people don't overd
deliver for their people is cuz they
they don't want to hear the
truth you like that one huh right and
it's hard honestly as someone who's
pretty damn good at wanting to hear the
truth even I have 10% of the things I
really don't want to know but I need to
like like I fight that last
10% so I'm like [__] I'm really about
this life what I just said and I got to
fight for the last 10% these people out
here are [__] in trouble yeah like
how one by one and in group settings I
would do a group all franchisees call
every month we do that beautiful but do
real [__] one of the things that I think
these two can speak to you can speak to
when I do all company hands on I don't
set the questions I just open it up for
questions and let people ask me
questions that is a level like to the
point where my team continues to keep
asking me like to set up the questions
because they're so scared of that level
of transparency she's like why did you
call me because this man went to high
school with you I know I want to say
something but I
don't how you doing good you guys can
talk later all
right go there okay like take that last
that last one's a big deal cuz right now
you're in a vulnerable spot where
retention matters if you're will willing
to go vulnerable and be accountable
you're going to have a high level of
retention on that small group right now
that are not family members that will
keep you surviving to when you break
through on some of the other [__] we
talked about cool thank you Jack awesome
so kind of set up our content the way it
runs so we have EP
brand platforms and then my own personal
our own personal Brands and then I've
got my photography on the side which
sense a pretty big following but
strictly swimming so I sh just share
photos there um but what you what you
can't fear is the occasional right hook
of like we interrupt these normally
scheduled programming to tell you I [__]
with drones too and let me give you a
preview because I have to do this and
it's humbling cuz nobody even the most
secure at the top of the game and you
know this right like you see me on the
team chat I will post [__] that I have
to do that I know won't do well but I
have to do it I want to see my normal
500,000 to a million views too but I
will take my 80,000 because I have to
tell you that Sasha wants you to sign up
for wine text and it's not fun to get
80,000 views but I'm in the business to
help my dad get you all to sign up for
wine which by the way you should all do
that if you buy wine um you're right now
scared to [__] up the gthm you're you're
picking the
algo and your subconscious insecurity of
hitting your numbers over getting two
customers from your photography world
into your drone
business it's not wild and you are like
one of everybody else so the people that
got four things going on [__] up the
thing that you have the most followers
on from your ideology for the
practicality of your business
that's true so then stick with me on
that you got me yeah like if your
photography think is your biggest
platform they won't love it but they
love you and if you're honest with them
be like you got to make the right piece
of cont if you just post like a flyer
and be like sign up for the Drone like
they're like what if you're like hey
real quick I know I'm [__] up like
you're self-deprecating I know like what
you want me from here just FYI I realize
a lot of you don't fully know me let me
tell you about myself I do this and that
and I grew up like got it do you keep
those when I keep those separate from is
where I do all the talking head and all
that or you you look I first of all and
a lot of you followed me for a long time
I was always the one that was
challenging you like do it all in one
place like I was always [__] people
up now I'm set because it's all based on
the content doesn't even [__] matter
you want a wild card start a new
account it doesn't matter you want to
really get [__] liberated it doesn't
matter perfect yeah it's a real brain
[__] to go from what we've been to where
we're at it's the
content it's the [__] content so I I
think if you're respectful of your
audience disrespecting your audience and
your photography is putting up a [__]
epic D like flyer like stupid like you
know like a piece of [__] post we all
know what that is right like a a picture
that's like [__] up and like sign up
now like like bad you making a video you
know and maybe a double setting like the
camera and the Drone in your hand and
just talking and being open with your
audience to your photography that's
going to work keeping them separate or
not I'm literally
agnostic I think at some level it helps
people organize I'm like very chaotic I
think a lot of people like like they
over you know this a lot of you are
getting [__] up because you care about
aesthetic you want your grid to look
right nobody gives a [__] about your
grid you know meaning I get it like I
don't want to discredit people going to
a grid and getting like I I I love brand
but [__] man 90% of the actions in feed
so if you're doing
grid for the aesthetic but it's not
following best practice to reach the
most audience in feed to what you're
trying to do what the [__] are you
accomplishing you don't get it Gary I
want people when they come to my account
to see it right I'm like they're not
coming to your account cuz you're trying
to make them look make it look right
you need the first part to
work awesome um so then for epic drone
specifically we do a really good job of
sharing our videos are dope of course
they're epic and then we do really well
with you like that that was good give me
some for that give
me all right um and then we do really
well behind the scenes so we show all of
our pilots flying and um we travel
across the country so we try to get as
much content when as possible they send
me iPhone videos and stuff but what's
the I feel like we have jab jab what's
the last like what's what do you want to
happen let's take a big step back what
would you when you post something on
social what would you like to
happen get customers obviously but no no
no let's like this is like a good game
play with me how many of the posts would
you like to do
that think one one every 10 would be
good so that this is a good game cuz one
could answer all of them one could
answer there's a lot of ways to think
about this there's no right answer so
let's say if you're thinking that way
which in a lot of ways I think of it
both ways I think one and I think in
those terms too jab to jab right hook
right but even when like even when I
like I know that the other nine are
building awareness and they may click
the URL in my profile in theory all good
content could be doing the sale but back
to you saying the sale back to me saying
I'm going to [__] up my grid sign up for
wine Tex right now
do you guys go hardcore for the ask for
business on every 10th
post do you see what I mean I'm telling
you there is a disease in marketing it's
called caring about the vanity metrics
over your
business we're having a logical business
conversation right now I'm like what
would you like to happen you answered
really thought like I liked your answer
think it's one of the smart places you
could have gone
but you're not doing it because you're
caring about the vanity meaning you
don't even like you're caring about the
algo it's algo over everything for
everyone and for me it's business over
algo but then what's what's the business
well I guess it's hard well how would
you talk how would you talk to me if you
wanted me to buy your
[__] that's I guess kind of what we're
what we're figuring out is like we can
give the you know you increase reach by
having better videos it builds a better
brand for the companies because they're
doing something nobody else is doing
is is that enough of course it's enough
what you're uncomfortable with is
getting enough nose to make you question
if it's
enough Vader media gets 90% NOS 10%
yeses so then what how CU I think the
people that we've worked with so far are
the capturing the demand is people that
are the go-getters they're doing the new
thing they I have good news for you
you're not going to convince people to
be more
ambitious so is there a way to kind of
create the demand
by I guess I guess we have a better hard
time getting the people that aren't
already looking for what we what we do
you haven't you haven't even gotten
remotely enough of a percentage of the
people that are
looking you're worried about convincing
the
non-con and you haven't even gotten 1%
of 1% of 1% of the
convinced that's what I looking for
you got it my brother one of the great
thing I you know it's I really
appreciate you understanding what just
happened I would argue that I'm not sure
if there's another thing bigger to my
professional success than having the
subconscious understanding at a very
young age that you can't convince the
unconvince don't convince just have
conviction I've been selling social
media since 2009 how old were you in
2009 12 good when you were 12 I was
walking around this Earth trying to sell
social media
Services nobody wanted it but I believed
and I found the small group that wanted
it and that's why we did $1 million in
Revenue the first
year awesome um so that you talk a lot
about the consumer segmentations we as
second kind of mentioned we have the
same services that we do but a can name
20 different correct the sentence you're
going to say to a hotel year is going to
be different than right right that's why
I say the same thing 73,000 times in a
100 different ways so how do you a
feedback we have gotten is a lot of
people that we're talking to come to our
page and they're like oh they only do
commercial real estate and they they
don't immediately see themselves then
they kind of assume that we can't help
them so how do you well then list them
all like I don't know what the website
looks like but literally it could be
like we have that website and we're
talking social it's like when they well
then we do a cool shoot with Padre's for
we have four posts on the padr well why
don't you have the bio say like Drone
footage for anyone and any
business that's good idea well I didn't
get here because of my
looks uh and then last kind of so for a
while i' I've always I've been the one
posting on social and being the front
and which I want to do for myself but
we're pretty soon going to be we are in
the process process of hiring social
media manager strateg whatever um what
is the best thing to have them start
right at the beginning like I can have
them do 20 things but what well I think
if you're going to hire someone I think
you want to ask her or him what they
think find someone that doesn't say to
have a better grid because that's what
all right if somebody said like like
this goes back to having a good strategy
yourself that's what you're here doing
correct like some of you now will
actually like let all of a sudden that
becomes your radar I meet people all the
time I talk to people all the time like
I get pitched to join Bor media at the
airport while I'm ordering a coffee and
I I'm weird I'll talk to them and when
they're like I can make your grd great
they're
out because I don't
agree I might be wrong but it's my
business like this is what I believe in
so yeah I think you should less focus on
what you should tell them to do at
first you at it's such a critical hire
at such a small business you need to put
yourself and there's so many talented
youngsters like they're just
everywhere but you need to know what you
believe and then you need to have them
present to you you're going to pay
them and then lastly sort of the future
organizational structure so right now
two of us were the only ones that are
like salary and work with we have two
basically full-time contractors uh cont
contractors we we're based in LA and San
Diego but travel everywhere we shoot in
Missouri next week we got two shoots
here in New York on I love it um so
that's kind of the model we're going
towards which is having a network of
contractors Mak sense for the inbound of
course you're a produ yeah you're a
production company rather than like
franchise with offices and full-time
people I mean becoming a franchise
franchise you know like it's an
incredible business model I'm sure you
know that that's why you went down that
path it's one of those classic things
that looks a hell of a lot better on
paper than reality it is hard it's the
reason it's so lucrative is because it's
hard I always say to people like like
they're like what what I want like I
want to Gary I want I could be anything
what should I be I'm like be a
professional basketball player like
that's a good idea that's a lot of money
like 50 like the bench players are
getting 30 like there's not that it's
not football there's 12 players right
there's 15 players is like like and
they're like what and the reason I
always say that is like well I can't do
that I'm like cool let's understand
that's true across the board you have to
first ask yourself if you're even a
franchisor are you a full-time
salesman basically good what I'm doing
now yeah I understand but how good are
you at it because right now getting some
clients to do production of Drone
footage may seem hard it's way harder to
convince someone to change their
profession to do you know what I mean so
no I think right now look I think you
you guys are so young I think there's so
much money in drone production companies
way more than you can imagine it's every
day we'll get better kind of like social
2009 and freelance is a great contractor
is a great business because you're not
locked in and James knows this I
demonize franchise freelance I always
hate it because I knew what I was
building something slightly it was a
good model day-to-day p
but I want to build family like forever
so like I needed employees to become
like I needed strangers to become
employees to become friends to become
family you don't do that like if I was
just going for margin I would only
freelance I would only contract it's
smart you're not locked in you don't
especially I have offices in New York
California if I wanted to fire people
it's impossible like you know it's hard
to do business in these states so like
you know no I think you got it right and
I think you got a long way to go and I
think we talked on some really good
stuff like like all that mind time you
spent on trying to convince people Drone
footage is good for them now imagine you
only focusing on people that have
already decided it
is that's why we crushed everybody were
competing with in 2009 was trying to
convince everybody of social media I was
spending all my time trying to find the
30 people that agreed and tried to
convince them right that's good yep I
talked to Juliet yesterday about it but
if you want to our team is here I would
love to do a fly through through the
office and show
up in EXA something quick and then we'll
be done okay oh yeah I guess the quick
one for me is since it's just been the
two of us we have a lot of overlap in
our what we're doing every day makes
sense and so one of the things is when
we're SK Jack's doing the sales I'm
doing scheduling he's partially
scheduling of course you guys of course
when you're a small small company you're
overlapping a ton that's also good
because now multiple people know the
full thing and so you grow like the
first seven or eight employees 15
employees I think should at to the best
of their capabilities be able to do
everything because now you've built
infrastructure for scale because you
could truly divide and conquer imagine
if for some reason Europe passed the law
and like the opportunity was
obnoxious the fact that one of you could
just go and move to Madrid while the
other like you know what I mean like
whereas if you only knew 20% of it you
couldn't overlap both of you get get in
the dirt both of you do the bougie part
like you just over mix all of it there's
really no bougie part at this small
right it's the one AI think we we do a
lot of AI in the copy and asking a
question site what what's the one thing
that you can use AI to go to I use AI to
think about what's happening in pop
culture like I ask AI things like why
did sexy red pop you know why why are
corduroy hats coming back like I like
you I like consumer insights and pop
culture that's why I'm who I am so I
don't think people realize you can use
AI to be your thinking partner you can
literally type into AI what would get
people to want to like use a kayak you
know insane that is I don't think right
now people are asking it to do tasks I'm
asking it to think with
me first question kind of going off of
the the messaging uh for the previous
two I think as a white label agency
trying to be the agency's agency it
feels like we're pitching concrete not
kayaks or drones right
makes sense how would you again agnostic
our goal is to get agencies in the door
CU we believe in I actually think I
actually going to throw you for a loop I
understand why you said that I actually
think it's the
reverse I got a really good one for you
so I understand that cuz you're B to B
Toc or B you're actually B to B Tob
um if you made content about the way I
did which is share best
practices you you're going to you're
going to get all you're going to get all
you may even get Brands reaching out to
you to tell you to work with their
current
agency you you're you're you're one very
great piece of LinkedIn content away
from 55 medium-sized businesses sending
that video to their current agency
telling them to hire you because like if
you just pounded again the same 15
messages 73,000
PE you know the biggest compliment I get
in my comments or DMS is when like Gary
you say the same [__] tired of
you biggest compliment I didn't think
you saw that I'm
sorry biggest compliment right because
yeah like what do you want me to make up
[__] I don't believe in I'm sorry I
believe in like there's only so many
things you can believe in and yes I'm
trying to interject today I'll say sexy
red 5 years ago I'll say the baby but
I'm saying the same [__] like it's like
I'm going to Incorporated to make it
relevant and I may pick up new
adjectives or get or expand my
vocabulary but like [__] this stuff is
tried and true this is why it's work
like this is why it's like simple like
yes and I intuitively knew it when I was
a kid which is why I did what I did but
now I'm [__] like double winning I'm
like knew it and it's true right and so
I actually think the reverse I think the
content that you are making about
operation
Excellence think about this video seven
cliche things that agencies do wrong you
can run that ad you can make that
content in different ways for the rest
of your
life and I think you'll actually get the
end C like you're just gonna like I
don't think your shit's boring as a
matter of fact I would argue something
really wild I think if you pounded what
I'm saying you may expand into other
areas
operational accellence is needed
everywhere he needs
it he's not an
agency if you do this content you might
end up having multiple
divisions right what's cool about what
you guys do is it's Universal it's why I
like marketing the ability to
communicate is universal everyone needs
it I'm chill all the time I need anyone
talk business I'm ready that's why I
never have to prep for speeches everyone
needs
communication the
government from the government of Dubai
to a guy selling pencils in a B2B
environment in Wyoming everyone needs
communication comes in different forms
back to your point concrete right but I
think yours is universal you selectively
chose through the history of this
company to be an agency of agencies but
operational excellence of course you
know deeper nuances of agency life but
it's not hard to pick up like you spend
one year with a franchisor and you'll
you'll like I know that to be true cuz
that's why I started an agency to figure
out how Universal what I was doing was
it's
Universal make sense yeah absolutely I
think you got to pound that I think you
just own unlimited content of
operational opportunities operational
fubs cliche op like pound pound Pound
what's the most universal mistake you've
seen agencies make like the true or a
universal mistake one that is quite
common every time you get involved I
think focusing on Ving metrics and not
sales so we are so focused on like
making sure tracking set up properly
because I don't give a [__] about your
click-through rate like it has to bring
the register for your end client and I
mean getting access to what we need to
do that is such a fight sometimes and
that's almost Insanity because like in
our sales process as we're working with
them the focus is on performance
performance performance and then we get
to it and it's almost like we're being
hamstrung because we're being forced to
talk about cpms and ctrs we just know
that it's not translated yeah what I
would do there is I would title a video
the reason most agencies lose a client
after the first year makes sense AB I
think like like that title why agencies
rarely hold on to a client for two
years and then you run that that on
LinkedIn on ads against agency employees
Watch What Happens the P agencies have
right build on that as much as possible
pound as much yeah think about I'm doing
I'm R engineering something that an
agency owner would like to understand
because what you just answered is the
reason the reason Vayner X is one of the
biggest agencies in the world today is
because I built it to do the actual
thing not the marketing jargon
thing you can have a trillion cpms it's
Why Super Bowl's the best and the
scariest the ad is the best you can't
get 110 million Americans to know
everything about you for $8 million even
if you're the best of day trading
attention the problem is crushing it in
a 30 second video is
hard I think that's part of my Fe I know
that I preach that but then I see the
cpms on LinkedIn and I'm just afraid to
even run too much Budget on that well
that's because you're a hypocrite
exactly I I love I I [__] love you
because what you know that I know is
that LinkedIn unlike every other
platform has an artificial floor on cost
on ad which is high what I know that you
also know but don't know as well as I
know is but who gives a [__] if you get
the thing that you want to happen and
that's what you preach on the other side
I prefer to pay higher cpms almost
always in anything that I own because I
want the actual thing I don't care about
anything other than how many people sign
up for wine text and buy
wine so the cpms if I'm buying low cpms
I'm getting bad
inventory if I'm paying high cpms I'm
getting people that are likely to buy
wine we figured this out with direct
mail a 100 years ago you can buy
everybody in town or you could pay AMX
to just send it to people who buy wine
yes of course it costs more the data is
valuable the customer is more valuable
for you in LinkedIn than it is on Tik
Tok no I just I just want to just dive a
little bit deeper we talking the
franchisees just how do we cut through
the noise just as partners in the BB
world for LinkedIn specifically the
quality of the content quality content
right like notice what like I'm so
[__] in it that I can give you that
title to a video and do the video and
know it will do better you break through
the Noise by the Merit of your
skills that people always say that Gary
how do I break through I'm like you have
to be
better like I don't like you know what I
mean yeah but but getting better comes
back to what I want all of you to be in
love with which is more reps this is why
like back to saying the same thing 800
different way somebody the other
day literally in comments because this
is what I do I read them Gary what is it
10 times a post 13 P 23 posts a day like
you say all these different numbers I
reply I'm like bro it's it's because I'm
just living my life it's there's no
actually it's just a lot as much as
humanly possible as once and for all as
much as humanly possible you're all
going to be doing it with AI anyway you
all in 9 years are going to have 4,000
ads a day so as much as possible you
know you know that goes back to like how
are you going to break through you're
actually not sure but you kind of know
it's the same thing that closes like
things why I'm good at content is I
watch what works in real life and I just
make content out of it what was the
sentence I said to make the person buy
it this is why I'm unstoppable I've been
selling since I was
five you know I've been practicing I
didn't read a book on how to [__]
what's that book influence people and wi
over what is it called like thank you I
just did it since I was five of course I
didn't have to read that [__] I lived it
I know I was popular I know why I was
the fifth grade president I know that
not why 94 people said no to me when I
rang their doorbell to shovel snow just
like I know why the six people said
yes and why the baseball card sold and
why when I changed the display cases at
my dad's store it sold and why when I
brought small bottles of wine at the
front of the register instead of peanuts
that that was good because the small
bottles of wine were 10 bucks and the
peanuts were 9 cents that was good I saw
it and I saw the 87 things that didn't
work when I did it I'm living it you
need to live it how do you break through
by doing so much content for so long
that you start to get an understanding
of the thematics that work if you think
that I woke up one morning and said you
know what we're going to do in [__]
August 2023 on my Instagram in this
highly competitive environment we're
going to make a
meme that captures the essence of the
video and we're going to do a two poost
Carousel because that's going to get the
most organic reach I promise you I had
no [__] idea if you think I thought
making photos that says that has a
picture of me in it that then says the
person that's sending you this thinks
and then whatever the [__] we've written
was going to be the consistent million
organic reach post that is the I when I
first posted the first one I'm like this
has no
shot
reps how'd you get those
muscles outside of [__] cheating
which you can't do in business no
steroids in business bro how'd you get
those muscles I [__] worked even the
really funny meme and culture of like
you're not ugly you're poor I think
about that I'm like right there's a
proxy that made someone look more
attractive it was called money like it
one could see that cynically in the way
that I think we should because I think
it [__] up people but there's a
different way to look at it which is
like nothing happens unless you do
something you know what I mean like yes
of course like for you know one could
Envy if you put Beauty on a pedestal
like somebody having the ability to have
plastic surgery and this and that and
that but there's still something that
happened otherwise it wouldn't have
happened like there's always cause and
effect we're in full control of this
right you guys can answer you can all do
what I do if you put in the 700,000
pieces of content that I did you won't
need me anymore I don't want anyone to
meet me I want them all to do what I'm
saying and never need me again they know
the answers before I
do I think last question that that we
have would be what has been the biggest
impact you've seen AI have on agency
life I haven't looked I mean I can give
you a ton of answers to that I think
first of all the biggest impact it's
going to have is on the the creative
product but right now there's too much
copyright and trademark stuff that has
to be figured out but that the biggest
impact is companies are going be like
4,000 pieces of ads a day instead of
four ideation I think like of course
back to what I said earlier strategy is
going to use it the way I do thinking
partner like why are corduroy hats cool
again and you start working what will 42
to 48 year old moms in Iowa when he
ready when he when he has a new
franchisee in De Mo
Iowa today it's not top of mind for him
to go to chat gbt or something like it
and say you know what will get people to
buy to buy a kayak service in De Moine
Iowa but in six years it will be I'm old
enough James is old enough to know that
people's first move wasn't to go to a
search engine in
2000 you know and now they do now
everybody here is like look that up
that's just normal that's going to be
normal you working with AI along the way
of everything will be normal so it's
going to have profound effect and it
will commoditize certain things if you
were a designer who doesn't have a
thought in her or his brain and you just
sit there and someone else tells you
what to make completely you have a
problem but if you are a designer who
ideates and thinks and you're creative
you're fine that's it either you're a
commodity or you're not and I don't say
that like dismissive it's just the way
the world worked you know most of us
worked on a farm 150 years ago then
tractors came and we didn't need
to I think as a matter of fact I I'm so
optimistic I think someone now who is
just like a non-creative non-thinking
designer and just a part of the I think
she or he finds something better on the
back end of that
so in terms of Storytelling what's one
blind spot that you've observed in
Mission based organizations whether it's
something like the shed or like Planned
Parenthood so I'm I'm in a I'm in a lot
of nonprofits and when I join the board
or advisory or come in to help the
number one thing I say is the number one
thing that causes struggle with is
audacity they're audacious to think that
just because it's a cause everyone
should do
it's
audacity like you know
like I understand that you my brother
has Crohn's disease I have a pretty good
feeling that I care more about Crohn's
and Colitis Foundation than other people
in this room unless they're affected by
it it's how it works it's why we can't
like the biggest problem with the world
is lack of
compassion same with cause like I
understand that all of you think that
there's a profound social impact of the
Arts
other people don't
care and so taking that knowledge to
know that people that you
can't convince right focus on the high
propensity correct but then focus on the
micro realities an 83 year-old Widow on
the upper west side who has a tremendous
trust right thinking about those kind of
D she's going to be compelled with
different storytelling than a young
artist who's 24 who was born in Jamaica
and immigrated here at five that's
growing up in Queens is going to think
about the shed and both can play this
goes back to an right and I remember my
early meetings with the shed like really
early even with the board before all of
you were in place I remember listening
I'm like [__] this is going to be a
problem and not from like a bad place
but I just knew that they were trying to
understand like there was incredibly
good intent of bringing diversity and
diversity of arts and all this it was
really cool and I could see they were
struggling with like how to make that
connection point to like where the
dollars and all these different things
and I was like it's and it's and it's
and you can do both but from a
storytelling standpoint you've got to
matter to the upper east and upper west
side as much as you have to matter to
Brooklyn and the lower west side and
those need different stories which is
why they need different restaurants
which is why they have different schools
which is why they have different Parks
it's different and and it's and our lack
of capacity for and is hurting us across
the board yeah I think we talked a
little bit about dinner last night y not
living in the that's right everybody
humans desperation to make the world
black and white when it's gray
is
devastating I could promise you almost
everyone's anxiety here on any level
about anything is based on
Andor G do you think BR is more
important in non for-profit world than
the business world and the only reason
why I say that is because the business
world we know who our competitors are in
the non for-profit you're you're
competing for dollars whether you know
whether you're arts or whether yeah I
mean you know look I I think it's it's
tough in the way you framed it up like
yes and no I mean like Nike would be out
of business if it didn't have a
brand like actually you know like I
understand what you're saying um I think
in some ways it's pretty universal
meaning
you just want as many people to not only
know who you are but be compelled to
consume
you right like it's just very like I
think about like Smart Water I'm looking
at that bottle in the right like that
could be a purchase of convenience right
it might have just been what was there
but where'd you buy that it was it was
here right fair enough why' you buy it
yeah exactly but I think that you know I
think about that a lot which is like why
you know sometimes it's price often
times it's convenience whichever one was
on the proper shelf which is why Brands
pay for slotting fees but a lot of times
in water we've convinced everyone you've
got to make a
choice I mean even I was a kid when like
you for damn sure and definitely me like
we didn't even sell water was in the
[__] sink I remember when the Poland
Spring big bottles for a start I'm like
that's a [__] hustle they convince
people to buy that [__] it's in the
sink I remember that now we're paying
this
[__]
$8 right what a job brand can do brand
matters everywhere brand is how you
charge eight bucks for coffee brand is
how we convince people to drink
something that is free for most
people um and brand is how someone
decides to take a million dollars and
give it to them versus somewhere else or
to go to their show like think about the
options in New York City and go to the
shed tonight and check out the exhibit
or I could do I don't know 700,000 other
things we're not in a small town right
you know and so it goes back to ant you
have 10 platforms that matter from
LinkedIn to you right you have 13 to the
thing you have to do is create
cohorts every yeah please you got time
everybody needs to create
cohorts the cons yep the consumer groups
you're trying to get for
them they're not going to get Vayner
media and they probably understand that
I don't think they're like trying to get
droga 5 they have a good sense they have
a good sense of the range but I also bet
that Coastal agencies may act
differently than middle of America
agencies agencies that are run by 22 to
30 year olds are acting different than
right so now you start making cohorts so
their cohort might be 22 to 30y Old Gary
V wannabes I mean this because it's a
very good cohort if I was their business
22 to 30y Old Gary V
wannabes um male Gary V wannabes who are
running under 10% agencies that's a
cohort next is 40 uh 45 to 60y Old
agency owners in Middle America who've
been doing it for 20 plus years now all
of a sudden when they wake up in the
morning and they have to make content
they're like they look at their cohorts
you can imagine they're going to make a
very different video literally the
opening line could be like hey did you
start your agency because of Gary ve you
know what we've seen from people like
that's gonna if they target people that
follow Gary B that's like a good idea
well that video has to be very different
to like hey are you tired of the last 25
years not being able to hold on to right
and maybe in that one it's a little more
Midwest values then like maybe you drop
an F bomb in the Gary
V1 that's called cohorts a 83-year-old
trustee woman on the upper west side
who's a Target that tends to do really
well for something like the shed versus
35-year-old you know minority in a
Brooklyn townhouse cuz they made it
themselves both could be in the shed and
could be impactful need completely
different
content right the and again the end
again which means your Grid's going to
be [__] up but if you want to protect
the grid because you have a board that
looks at the bridge
grid then you run ads and it never shows
up on the grid we also talked about a
team account on Tik Tok versus a shed
account that's right there's a lot of
ways to do it or you create a general
account on Tik Tok that you own called
New York
Arts that just happens to only do shed
it
content right like for me I can make a
if my dad was rigid and didn't want me
to do the right thing for him i' be like
cool I wouldn't try to convince my dad
I'd tell branded my best friend to
create a Tik Tok called wines of New
Jersey and just post there so my dad
doesn't look at it luckily I won that
battle with my dad 35 years ago but but
if that was the case which it could be
for all the people that have a family
business where your mom and dad is about
that grid life if you're about my life
don't
fret if you know just create Convenience
Stores of
Indiana and on Tik Tok and just pound
your
[__] because now you don't have to have
right remember the old game uh but this
account has 100,000 followers on it that
we build up and I'd have to start at
zero woe is me today it doesn't matter
it's the individual post gives all of us
a lot more
flexibility did you get your question um
I think my question is more General we
talk a lot about like convincing is like
them not to convince yes have conviction
how do you navigate that as like an
entrepreneur or young Prof professional
when it feels like when you are young
you have to convince like you have to
get people on your side by understand
accomplish anything well there's two
things as an entrepreneur it's easy
because it's you in the
market and you figure it out by
realizing it's
true but I think you're more talking
about being an
employee you know when you're young as
an entrepreneur like you don't have
anyone to have to comein as a matter of
fact you could have a business and no
one even know how old you actually are
it's when you're an employee that to
your point one first of all the youth
has it better than any other youth when
we were all growing
up like the youth today has way more
respect from their Elders in
professional settings than we we did
because of all the technology shifts you
have leverage people respect you on [__]
you didn't even get talked to for a
decade as an employee right like it
wasn't even like right now I have people
here for a year thinking like when am I
going to be a VP and I'm like
[__] do you understand that
you'd be getting coffee for the first
next four years of your life you
wouldn't even be able to talk in the old
days like you know what I mean so a by
recognizing you have it better which is
really comforting like there's never
been a generation that's had it better
which has led to some of the friction
because they have it so good two by
being empathetic to them you know I
think the way 20 year olds break through
is through empathy they come in hot
because they do know a lot of [__] but
boy do they not know a lot of [__] I'm
sitting here saying that I don't know 13
big things in business and I'm like
about that life and I have a lot of 20y
olds coming in think that they got it
and they don't no one does so having
empathy for why your boss might think
that but to your point you're absolutely
right when you're an employee you are
often trying to convince but I feel the
best form of convincing Ving is
conviction and conviction looks
different than convincing convincing is
when you're trying to figure out what
the board will say yes
to conviction is telling them the truth
consistently until you break
through right agency's biggest
vulnerability by the way to you is being
yes men and women to
clients the reason we win is we have
conviction and we let the chips
fall the reason agencies lose
as they say how high every
time they just want the money in the
short
term same with a board the reason I can
win with boards is I'd rather get fired
but I will respectfully answer the truth
like for you to win respectful
conviction I have notice how I get
things done I respect that you care
about the grid I understand why you care
about the grid now let's talk about
about the
truth the truth is it's an infeed game
the truth is I can still do my thing
ready I get a know I've reference that
as well oh I can't then I'm going to run
ads that won't show up on the grid got
it conviction versus like these [__]
people don't get
it that's all that I hear from
everyone right that's where you go they
don't get it cool the thing that I
always do to inspire youngsters I'm like
if they don't get it you go do it but as
long as you're taking that paycheck from
it you've got to figure out how to have
if you're going to convince it's going
to come from conviction not compromising
convincing any party so this is our
first time using the 4ds to teach people
sock so we're going to do some ideation
around cohorts we're going to talk about
brand forance we got a lot of b2bs in
here that I think struggle more with
understanding how sock applies so do you
have any words of wisdom go into the
afternoon yep the best example of suck
and cohorts I gave were a B2B
environment example it was for
them this is real it will work you know
I would go in with
openness walk in with maybe heading to
yes instead of no and excuses and then
during the process ask questions awesome
thank you thank
you
[Music]
yeah